très intéressant on apprend plein de
choses je vous parle aujourd'hui la les
nouveaux yoga c630 qui équipé du
qualcomm snapdragon 850 alors le
qualcomm fabrègues du 150
c'est le premier processeur soc effet
exclusivement pour pc pour faire tourner
votre pc on vient de l'univers du
smartphone mais sur pc c'est pour ça
qu'on est à chenilles chemin entre un pc
et un smartphone
je vous explique le truc c'est vraiment
pas suivre
[Musique]
on a déjà parlé il ya quelques temps je
ne sais pas si vous vous souvenez je
vous avait emmené à londres on avait
parlé d euros s connectique plessis
always the passing wings
si c'est pas le cas c'est pas grave on
va prendre aujourd'hui calmement
tranquillement vous allez voir qu'on va
parler justement d'abord dit qui en fait
est un ordi sans être un dandy c'est ça
qui est vraiment intéressant les ordis
vous connaissez on parle souvent de
intel intel core i5 i7 enough sont un
des processeurs un peu standard même
s'il évolue d'année en année en termes
de puissance de performance d'autonomie
et compagnie mais ce sont des
processeurs plus standard vous permettre
d'utiliser votre ordinateur façon plus
classique est à dire vous l'allumez vous
l'utiliser quand vous voulez l'utiliser
vous éteignez et tout se passe bien
c'est l' usage alors des fois on va le
garder en vicier ça mais dans l'absolu
c'est pascal mieux ce qui est bien c'est
ce paysage un petit peu standard et
justement on arrive avec sept niveaux
avec cette nouvelle dur à dire c'est que
vous on arrive que cette nouvelle
typologie de bécanes notamment exception
gas et 630 ou là on arrive dans autre
chose c'est ce qu'on appelle always
found always connected pc je vous ai
fait que trempettes c'est comme votre
smartphone ou votre smartphone y est
toujours allumée vous avez juste à
appuyer sa l'allument salles et 1 ça
marche c'est un smartphone classique ces
standards eh bien c'est exactement la
même chose avec votre pc
avec cette typologie de machines c'est à
dire que vous le prenez je le prends je
lui ouvre tac
j'ai un petit bouton et il est allumé
pas besoin de l'état n'a pas besoin de
se dire je veux atteindre windows
alumine haussier ça non vous l'avez en
permanence allumées avec vous et ça
c'est l'innovation et c'est vraiment ça
qui est hyper intéressante
qu'est ce que ça change d'ailleurs tous
ça ça change un peu les usages c'est à
dire que vous avez toujours votre ordi
qui va travailler en tâche de fond qui
va pouvoir relever des emails faire un
peu ce que vous voulez ce qui fait que
vous avez une machine qui est toujours
un jour ça c'est cool
et en plus de ça puisqu'on parle aux
oiseaux nice et aix est toujours allumée
always connected sur cette bécane là
vous avez ici un petit tiroir pour
insérer une carte sim pour avoir de la
data et c'est ça qui est vraiment hyper
intéressant vous avez votre ordi qui est
toujours allumée en gouaille zone qui
est toujours connecté à internet
always connected c'est une nouvelle
génération dorny qui commencent à
arriver qui arrive doucement c'est
qualcomm qui fabrique cette technologie
issu des processeurs de smartphones pour
arriver qu sur les pc là on l'a sur un
ordi de lenovo
et au final c'est plutôt cool tout
justement on va regarder ça on va le
tester sur cet ordi 107 yoga ces 630
on va déjà faire le tour de la machine
voire en plus qu'on peut faire les
usages et je vais vous dire après mon
ressenti mon expérience réelle par
rapport à ce nouveau type de produits on
va parler de leur dire lui-même c'est
vrai qu'il est chouette plutôt bien fait
belle finition beau travail après les
nouveaux connaît vraiment sa copie afin
de que la travaille vraiment bien et
surtout ce qui est vraiment cool avec
cette série yoga c'est qu'on peut
vraiment faire ce qu'on veut on peut
l'utiliser comme un pc comme ça on peut
l'ouvrir comme sam la saq globalement
peu d'intérêt surtout vous l'utilisez
après en petite tablette sur vous et sur
vos genoux quand vous venez bosseur un
truc est vraiment cool on a donc un
produit sympa simple à utiliser
pratique pour bosser pour regarder des
films comme ça vous le prenez vous
mettez sur vos genoux ça va complètement
venir bloquer le clavier derrière vous
avez absolument aucun problème il ya là
qui bouge c'est vraiment cool hop ça
regardez vous le posez comme ça plus
regarder un film si vous avez une petite
appli pour faire des dessins à vous
faire des petits dessins à bout de doigt
parce que vous voulez pas qu'il ya
vachement des usages à voir avec ce set
youga yoga ces 630 en plus vous avez
vraiment une belle finition avec une
charnière on dirait presque qu'il va
s'envoler comme un petit oiseau
on a une belle finition avec cette
charnière qui est franchement cool on a
vraiment sa tion de robustesse là dessus
c'est un dès lors dit c'est quelque
chose de bien que je trouve bien fini de
la part des nouveaux en tout cas il ne
serait ce que sont la partie charnière
on a en plus ici un petit capteur
d'empreintes digitales pour venir le
déverrouiller très facilement c'est
rapide c'est pratique c'est sympa on a
un écran qui est pas mal c'est une dali
ps et du lcd avec une tv net de 13,3
pouces avec une résolution de 1920 par
1080 cdu fhd par contre qu'un peu
bizarre c'est le fait d'avoir cessé de
grande partie noire en bas c'est vrai
que c'est assez disgracieux ça nous fait
une grande barre noire en bas une barre
noire qui a c'est au grand dossier en
haut pour venir à cacher si la petite
webcam c'est pas le truc le plus moderne
le plus actuel au niveau de l'audio vous
avez deux haut parleurs en haut parleurs
de chaque côté on a un son stéréo le son
lorsque vous l'écoutez comme ça il est
quand même assez médium on pourrait
s'attendre à voir un tout un peu
en terme de qualité sonore ouais c'est
un petit peu un point de regret sur
cette décade à petit sa connectique vous
avez si une prise mini jack 3.5 vous
allez augmenter un peu la qualité audio
le spectre à un peu meilleure bouffe et
un casque qui soit pas trop mauvaises
qui était derrière pour pouvoir en
profiter c'est pas officines mais ça
marche à côté de ça on n'est pas
nécessairement sur un ordi qui est
optimisé pour le multimédia
c'est plus un ordinateur qui est
optimisé pour le professionnel pour le
déplacement pour le nomade
parce que justement vous avez un truc
est super cool c'est cette fameuse carte
signe que vous venez insérées là donc la
regarde et hop je viens ici c'était
facile à connecter je vais avoir soi
mais wifi se cachent pour me connecter
soit ici mon réseau mon réseau
directement enquête j'ai je clique
jeunes connect et hop ça y est je suis
connecté
lorsque je sais pas vous mais moi je
suis souvent en déplacement et j'ai un
mac j'ai pas la possibilité de connecter
mon mac on réseau 4g c'est vrai que ça
me manque alors du coup je me jette
passé par partage de connexion de mon
smartphone dont ça se fait c'est pas non
plus d'un gramme mais c'est vrai qu'à le
prendre
l'ouvrir vous connecter directement ou
avoir reçu directement tous vos emails
en tâche de fond
lorsque vous êtes sur un usage pro vous
avez souvent besoin vous n'êtes pas en
train de vous embêter votre ordi est
toujours un jour vos emails sont
toujours relevé c'est vraiment génial
comme je les ai seront loués ce
collectif et c'est always on a les
nouveaux 600 la lenovo 6,6 la lenovo
c630 c'est dur à dire là les noces et
636 le dire rapidement vous allez voir
c'est un peu la galère
cette fameuse enovos et 630 chaud elle
tourne sur le site un dragon 850 qui est
en gros une version adaptée du stade
ragone 845 pour smartphones qui marche
bien
à côté de ça c'est pas une machine qui
est hyper performantes faire tourner des
jeux c'est pas une machine qui fait pour
gaming c'est pas une machine qui va le
plus de performances comme ce que vous
pourriez avoir avec un intel core i7
on est quand même en dessous j'attends
l'évolution qu'il arrive fin 2010 9 des
12 2020 du côté de chez qualcomm avec un
snapdragon qui va être complètement
fabriquée dédiés uniquement pour le pc
est là à mon avis on va vraiment avoir
une belle évolution pour connais la
force de frappe de qualcomm mariage est
absolument aucun doute sur leur capacité
à vous proposer un processeur
complètement optimisé dédié qui va
vraiment venir rivaliser avec ce que
fait une telle qu on arrive à avoir les
mêmes performances avoir une autonomie
accrue avec les machines qui est
toujours connecté à mon avis on va
arriver sur autre chose et c'est là
vraiment houleux
marché des pc va évoluer parce que si
vous faites attention à ça laisse avec
le marché du pc mises à part quelques
petites innovations mises à part voyez
vous comme l'assurent une yoga le fait
qu'on va se plier le fait de pouvoir se
détacher un écran au conseil jean corne
on est sur des petites innovations là le
fait d'avoir un pc portable toujours
connecté facile à lui mais sans se
prendre la tête c'est une belle
évolution et croyez moi dans le monde du
pc ça ça fait du bien mais sur une
machine qui a 8 gigas de ram 128 go de
stockage qui fonctionne plutôt bien là
dessus sur lequel vous pouvez regarder
youtube netflix en hdr s'associent cool
maintenant il ya un truc aussi regretter
c'est le fait qu' il n'y ait pas
beaucoup de connectique dessus vous avez
deux ports usb c'est un port usb c'est
ici qui permettra de le recharger
vous avez la petite icône qui est juste
là bas aussi ça je vous le dis c'est
pour brancher votre carte sim et un
deuxième port de l'autre côté et c'est
tout alors vous avez effectivement ici
votre petite prise jack pour brancher un
casque votre bouton pour l'allumer pour
l'éteindre c'est vrai qu'on manque un
peu de connectique alors c'est vrai que
souvent sur ce genre d kahn actuellement
c'est pas forcément que chez lenovo on
aimerait bien avoir un peu plus de
connectique une prise en usb à ça
pourrait être cool des fois des ports
hdmi pour avoir un moniteur externe ça
pourrait être assez intéressant
il vous faut pour ça utilisez un dock
externe en usb c est là tout s'ouvre à
vous la fois faire plein de choses avec
ça c'est cool
le clavier est pas mal je trouve que les
touches sont assez grandes plutôt bien
on a un bon retour de toucher henry 6
mois suis sur un clavier en qwerty parce
que j'ai un ordi anglais mais vous
pouvez aussi la voir un azerty quand
absolument aucun problème
clavier agréable touche assez grande une
forme assez sympa de ce point de vue là
y aussi un beau boulot de fait c'est
tordu l'autonomie est assez bonne en a
une dizaine d'heures un peu plus de dix
heures pour votre autonomie ce tout ça
c'est bien ton arrivée sur la prochaine
génération au niveau du snapdragon on
ira plus loin en terme d'autonomie en or
nothing qui sera encore plus puissante
avec une meilleure autonomie et ça je
vous le dis une fois de plus pour que ça
va vraiment changer l'histoire en tout
cas cet ordi moi je le trouve vraiment
cool vraiment intéressant prévenir à
naviguer faire ce que vous voulez voyez
c'est très pratique c'est sympa de nous
coûter c'est la moindre des choses
lorsque vous allez avoir une machine que
vous apportiez comme ça si l'écran n'est
pas tactile
cette toute petite à être un petit peu
plus compliqué je trouve cet ordi
intéressant c'est une belle proposition
tant du côté de les nouveaux venus
proposer cette yoga c630 qui est cool
qui est un tarif de 1199 euros
effectivement peu trop des ordinateurs
un peu moins cher avec des meilleures
performances mais vous n'aurez pas
vos produits always connected always
sonné avec votre petite carte sim à
l'intérieur et puis surtout dans la
série yoga à chaque fois le fait qu'ils
puissent faire va très clairement du
yoga comme ça ça pour moi c'est vraiment
vraiment cool si cet ordi vous intéresse
je vous ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description et moi je vais arrêter avant
de le faire tomber pour ça vraiment
intéressant et je suis très curieux de
voir ce que qualcomm va nous proposer
fin d'année 2010 9 débile 2020 pour
beaucoup de domaines apprend beaucoup de
choses notamment au niveau du nouveau
processeur de smartphone est également
au niveau des pc parce que je pense
qu'il ya on arrive dans une nouvelle ère
au niveau des pc on arrive dans quelque
chose d'un peu de neuf
je sais que tout le monde va forcément y
croire à se dire bon est ce qu'on a
besoin de ça on a besoin d'avoir un ordi
qui est en permanence allumées en talent
en train de relever vos emails est ce
que ça peut aussi être problématique
ça dépend de vos usages une fois de plus
si c'est leur dit qu'ils aient posé à la
maison n'avait pas forcément besoin mais
si comme moi vous déplacer beaucoup et
vous voulez pas galérer à faire un
partage de connexion à chopin wifi qui
est suffisamment rapide ou alors aller
sur dix huit filles publiques n'ayant
pas forcément de vpn derrière donc on
est pas forcément hyper sécurisé et là
vous êtes à mettre beaucoup plus
sécurisé vous êtes beaucoup plus
tranquille vous gérez votre consommation
vous êtes peinard et dès lors vous avez
la 4g vous êtes heureux ou heureuse
dites moi ce que vous en pensez un banc
aux commentaires qu est ce que vous
pensez des nouveaux pc comme ça always
connected always-on est ce que vous
trouvez ça cool oui ou non qu'est ce que
vous pensez de cette nouvelle et yoga
c'est 630 une fois de plus c'est dur à
dire mais j'y arrive ça c'est cool
vous marquez tout ça en bas et quant à
nous on se retrouve dès demain nous
promet foad maintien
[Musique]